quel d'arc à
armando
mais bon jour serena no la brigade des
mineurs
commencent à marmande au
pérou armando s'excuserait ça
je me dis que c'est un petit accent du
noirmont doimo série qui est super dans
la vie parce que
j'ai besoin du nous rassure
du trafic de voitures
d'accord d'accord et sinon tu veux tu
fais quoi
soit non ça va
[Applaudissements]
armand dont tu es tu reçois nom est tu
tombe bien parce qu'on a quelqu'un qui
est malade
son petit coeur est malade son petit
coeur est blessé armando cette personne
c'est daniel un bandeau j'ai posé
d'abord une petite question ouais c'est
la question après et après cette
question pourrait y voir beaucoup plus
clair
armando es-tu célibataire déjà
[Applaudissements]
armando e m tu as quel âge
cinquante neuf à s'énerver
à bordeaux j'ai l'impression que tu
coach toutes les cales
armengaud dernière question est ce que
tu as envie d'une histoire d'amour ou
est ce que tu veux juste trempé ton
biscuits
à côté que sur la
une bonne histoire je te bien sûr que je
te disais que tu sur la personne
armando qu'est ce qui te plaît chez
daniel
alors pour l'instant c'est toujours à
nous
parce que toi vous serez tout ça dans la
chambre ne trompe pas
c'est sûr il va barder surprise vient
à armando alors qu'est ce qui te plaît
chez daniel
tu passes sous lantus ou lots situés
passant sous marin du passé du pathos
mal
moi je trouve qu'elle cartonne avec son
compère
[Rires]
mathieu dentiste après demande inquiète
pas ce sera juste une petite résine
qu'on va mettre sur la b12 et ceux-là 14
paquet passerelle d'où elle a beaucoup
de charisme et ça se voit pas ça se voit
pas l'antenne se sauve à palente est oui
alors oui il en plus curieux john c'est
une personne cultivée est
tout à fait la personne qu'il nous faut
et bien si j'étais déjà sur antenne du
nord
le matin je suivais déjà ah ouais
attendait le cantal avait 26 ans
daniel franchement alors moi je vous le
dis je suis séduit par un monde
il est il à la voix est là il a une voix
magnifique il est rigolo il est sérieux
il il a des pilotes 500
merci daniel jault prégnant je propose
c'est le propose que daniel du parle
pendant une minute en tant qu'athée rien
tu dis oui donc demandé à tout le public
de fermer les yeux et d'imaginer armando
et daniel lui
daniel ont parlé pendant une minute en
seul à seul je ne ferai aucun
commentaire
oui promis tu vas prendre ce téléphone
ce téléphone c'est peut-être le
téléphone de l'amour
pas en soi et vous allez entendre bah
oui
armando bon soir
alors qu'elle d'hôtel rôle de mouche
vous a piqué de poser votre candidature
comme ces patrons mots l'enjeu
comptable et les rues que vous avez
écrit déçu car
j'ai vu que vous avez une peine de coeur
à tous et y est follement amoureuse de
ce soir est décidé d pas libre amanda
knox jugée si le contacter
génial c'est une question qu'on invente
un vote positif parce que daniel n'était
intéressé que par des personnes qui ont
des noms de familles d'animaux poulain
couleur
est annoncée un an doc est pas
c'est vrai
c'était une petite blagounette de cyrine
c'est
bien est ce que tu as envie les
habitants oui mais alors en plus j'adore
aix en provence dont premier bon point
et est ce que vous êtes
enfin vous êtes célibataire depuis
longtemps vous êtes un petit peu chaud
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu as les bonus que vous
êtes un mythe vous êtes un petit peu
chaud quoi est-ce que ça
est ce qu'elle est c'est parce qu'elle
m'avait parlé
[Applaudissements]
ma culture mais ya pas que ça dans la
vie
il ya quelqu'un derrière
ces séries
me dis des conneries que je vous dirai
peut-être mais quand on s'est
traduit par
je vous perturbe en fait c'est ça
par exemple je peux pas basket il ya
tout le monde ici donc je peux pas vous
demander de me parler de votre vieille
quoi c'est pas possible
[Rires]
vous savez que ça me ressemble pas c'est
si c'était pour faire éviter ça voilà
c'est tout faire
cuisiner ça se fait tout seul
est
ce que tu penses que tu peux tenir
semaine prochaine
abbas mais le coach est avec nous et on
fera la grande rencontre sur le plateau
et ça sera pour moi vous irez dîner tous
les deux au flunch
routier sans scrupules
[Applaudissements]
alors les mecs là là là quelqu'un
jusque là où il fallait à la france -
nom n'a même si c'est incroyable et puis
ce mec il est parfait et il est parfait
mais c'est le parfait mieux parfait